What's up, Marvel fans?
We're here with Kevin Feige.
This is a huge
undertaking of a film.
Where did you start?
We started at
the ending of Far
From Home, where
we knew that we had
put Peter Parker in a very
hard circumstance where
his identity was revealed.
And from there, we
decide what happens next.
And how do we make
things harder for him?
He's been to space.
He's become Spider-Man.
He's lost his mentor.
And now his identity
is revealed.
And all he wants to do
is graduate high school
and go to college.
And we started there.
And the good old
Parker luck kicked in.
You brought supervillains in
from previous Spider-Man movies
into this.
What was that process like?
It was very emotional.
It always starts with a place of
what do we think would be fun,
what do we think would be cool.
I've been making movies
for 20 years now at Marvel.
And they started at this very
theater, as a matter of fact,
with the premiere of Sam
Raimi's Spider-Man 1.
And we were sitting
around a room
and saying if I saw Willem
Dafoe, who you just talked to,
as Green Goblin again and Alfred
Molina, who's not able to be
here tonight, as Doc Ock,
I would lose my mind,
just that starting point.
And a lot of luck came together
that they were interested.
We were able to bring them back.
Oh that's incredible.
I can't wait to see
this incredible film.
What are you most
proud of throughout
the Spider-Man films?
Well, I'm proud
of the collaboration
we've had with with Jon
Watts on three movies,
with Tom Holland on
three of his own movies
plus the Avengers movies.
The entire relationship between
Sony and Marvel and Disney
is really unprecedented
in Hollywood history.
And it's all because
everybody loves Spider-Man.
And that is amazing.
And I hope it shows in
all the movies as well.
Well, you said everyone
loves Spider-Man.
What makes him so
lovable and relatable?
I think that was
the genius of what
Steve Ditko and Stan Lee
did all those years ago
was they made him us.
They made him
flawed and related.
And again, here he is in this
giant, anticipated movie that
may or may not have
consequences for the Multiverse,
but Peter Parker just
wants to go to college.
Peter Parker just wants
to graduate high school.
That's it.
And you want to root
for that person.
Kevin, thank you so much.
Enjoy the movie.
Thank you so much.
Have a good night.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]